hello and welcome to this video
well no even have the number right yeah
okay so well let's play the English
opening smallish movie three I know it
doesn't look like in English yet but
well we usually get there by another
three already
of course yeah here many moves Seaforth
interesting there are many possible
transpositions here like here we are
getting into him in the position that
could easily get on the board via tirage
Queen's Gambit Arash we can also view it
as an Enzo Indian variation with white
being a tempo up it's a it's kind of the
same Rubinstein Dems Oh reversed colors
10 Bob yeah let's see what Reena Chas
does with white playing this position
there would be Bishop d6 off Bishop d3
okay that looks a bit odd let's put some
pressure on d5 trying to take maybe okay
and it's also RT because man is he does
not have this b5 move available t2
orbital frankest e2
it was more like a gut gut feeling
decision okay so what's going on in this
position if I go hmm okay after Jake
that's not really up for debate
hmm what I didn't want
what position I've had taken their take
on c6 maybe this is a move intending to
take on c4
yeah Bishop before now as a a massive
threat so he has to castle I guess okay
yeah I'm going to go with them after a
five maybe have to give up an exchange
like Bishop III Knight c3 but I don't
care
b5 could be a nine could be an issue
though yeah anyway I can I can go there
first and then work out the details I
actually doubt that yeah I always can
move the Queen with a maid threat to
have three or to h5 both uh sir
dangerous disease to say the least just
wonder what's best queen g4 is also
quite strong queen g4 threatening Queen
g7 yeah I like that
I wonder if he can actually take on b1
might be one green g7 Knight takes a
three queen h8 cake can you say I'm
sorry
yeah I'm really sleep deprived from last
couple of weeks almost we suffered this
heatwave in Germany it's just like Oh
incredibly hot so what's it honestly
doing night b1 no I mean if he goes g6 I
wanted to Queen F forward then 92 is a
bit annoying to to put it mildly yeah I
mean actually I suspect that the
strongest could be yes simply that to
take on c4 if he goes g6 or something I
mean I think he has to do that
no more what's going on
yeah I mean let's look at it
Queen Queen f3 Liam I can't play this
without sacrificing that it's actually
quite a tempting thing to do but if I
just take this young you know and now
you won this position is absolutely
great yeah I thought that wouldn't do
work but I can take and have queenie
form and i cannot believe that this is
that you can survive that queenie for
walking to d7 like g5 knocking come on
it's probably probably winning would be
seven rooks c7 not entirely clear I mean
it looks terrible but what about Queen
to e5 by the way
it looks simple but strong the turned
out to be really too dangerous
yeah this is some pretty much unexplored
theoretical territory where white is
that tempo up on the names of which it's
just a tempo okay
played Bishop d7 93 trying to put more
pressure and he went c4 which okay Evon
that makes a lot of sense yeah opening
up the e-file could be a strong
suggestion by the computer you cannot do
this simply because of 95 then you're
killed so politics probably and then
wookie won
yeah it's a very quick way of attacking
you on de farm the engine doesn't really
give anything decisive but it looks
comfortable okay I played b3 push it
before Bishop d2 and a6
yeah not much choice I have to take
bishop tags and 95 your cake and 95 both
mayor both looks okay Alex e8 and I
played rook to be one now which is
approved by the computer okay I didn't
play it too badly after this point
Bishop takes Bishop takes 94 and of
course you go to before and not not
backwards any five Bishop e3 and now we
can never cancel this is just enormous
and I don't see what he should do here
be fire was yes he three something that
I have thought about but I thought just
repealed
like him he's got this pawn that's not
bad of course bad looks good for what
yeah after this I think black is toast
queen g4 g6
yeah now B takes a is best that you can
give up the exchange as I suspected you
can also keep it and be better but I'm
taking a strong and yeah it's probably
just gone I'm gonna be one more but I
supposed to play it's just it's just too
much the night only I have the bishop on
a three
yeah and him queen air force even better
okay anyway but this this is strong
enough five d5 also good now he had to
play this I think I probably would have
just taken with the bishop and it wins
as well yeah that was a there was to
slow development wise it was too slow
but black did like see what so very slow
okay guys thanks for watching